que bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir docteur le grand
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france un plan de sortie confinement
présenter largement donc avant le 11 mai
a dit le premier ministre en tant que
médecin qu'est-ce qu'on vous en attendez
on attend un plan de déconfinement avec
des moyens qui nous permettent de le
mettre en oeuvre
donc à savoir des masques en suffisance
c'est quand même la base absolue avant
de avant toute chose et surtout
probablement une politique de tests qui
soit n'ont pas basé sur un ciblage mais
qui soit fait en amont parce que les
caractéristiques techniques des tests
actuellement ne nécessitent des faits en
amont et non pas en aval de l'examen
clinique
alors effectivement vous parlez des
masques et des tests emmanuel macron on
a parlé lui aussi quand il a présenté
cette sortie de déconfinement 11 mai le
président évoqué un masque grand public
pour chaque français
concernant les tests ce sont des tests
qui serait destiné à des français qui
ont des symptômes à ne pas confondre
avec les tests de sérologie pour voir si
on a eu le virus est ce que c'est
suffisant pour le médecin de vous êtes
non pas du tout en fait c'est une erreur
de penser que des tests avec une
sensibilité à 0 60 % doivent être faits
sur une population à prévalence élevée
donc pour vous traduire ça classiquement
plus la population à un grand nombre de
malades donc à l'issue de l'examen
clinique du médecin on concentre les
malades et plus le nombre de faux
négatifs va augmenter et c'est ça qui
est inquiétant c'est que si on se fait
cette politique là avec le test que l'on
a on va libérer un grand nombre de
personnes qui sont porteurs et qui
seront les faux négatifs alors que quand
vous faites ce même test avec la même
sensibilité soit une population dont la
prévalence est plus faible c'est à dire
avant l'examen clinique et donc au
hasard on va dire à ce moment là vous
avez un rapport de
deux tests négatifs valides qui est
beaucoup plus important et c'est pour ça
que c'est ça ne doit pas être utilisée
de cette manière là nous sommes en
infectiologie et non pas en recherche de
tumeurs ça n'a strictement rien à voir
alors pardonnez moi docteur mais tout
n'est pas clair pour moi sur ces faux
les baies vitrées veut dire que quand on
a des symptômes qu'on vient vous voir
pour être testé ce n'est pas forcément
le bon moment le meilleur moment pour
que ce test soit sial quand je vois un
patient si je dis qu'il a le qu'ovide 19
je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir ce test là
pour l'affirmer puisque en réalité mon
examen clinique est suffisant et si je
le teste je risque d'avoir surtout des
faux négatifs et très peu de vrais
positif et donc du coup c'est une et
c'est une erreur c'est à dire que je
vais libérer des gens qui sont malades
en leur faisant croire qu'ils ne le sont
pas à cause du test la sensibilité de
60% c'est à dire que 40 % des malades
vont avoir un test négatif
si jamais je le fais avant mon examen
clinique donc dans une population avec
une prévalence élevée j'aurai beaucoup
moins de faux négatifs et donc je
libérerait - et mon test négatif aura
plus de valeur
or en épidémiologie c'est le test
négatif qui compte et non pas le test
positif on a près la même notion alors
le 11 mai effectivement réouverture
progressive des écoles déconfinement
partiels lui aussi à la lumière de ce
que vous nous dites ce que vous êtes
inquiet comment va-t-on s'en sortir à ce
que vous vous craignez une une deuxième
vague
la deuxième vague peut arriver
évidemment c'est ce que tout le monde
craint on ne pourra dès confiné que si
on a la capacité au niveau national de
produire des masques pour l'ensemble des
français parce que le premier
déconfinement c'est le masque et le
deuxième confinement c'est de confiner
les personnes étiquetées comme positif
au hasard par un test ou étiquetés comme
positif par le médecin et mais à partir
du moment où on n'a pas ces tests
sérologiques comment va-t-on savoir qui
est immunisée ou pas au virus est ce
qu'on compte finalement le gouvernement
compte-t-il sur une forme on en parle
souvent d'immunité collective ça veut
dire que voilà des gens vont attraper le
virus mais les hôpitaux pourront les
accueillir seront en capacité de le
faire
l'immunité collective c'est un doux
mythe puisque on est parti sur un syrien
début d' immunité collective à 50% que
maintenant on est déjà plutôt à 60% en
vue de la contagiosité du virus et qu'on
s'aperçoit que dans les zones de kloster
on n'a que 15 % de gens qui ont été
immunisés
ce qui veut bien dire que soit
l'immunité n'est pas ce qu'on sait quand
et donc pas durable ou pas suffisantes
soient très peu de personnes ont été
atteintes et à ce moment là le virus est
très virulent ce qui serait très
surprenant donc clairement faire le pari
de limiter collective c'est faire un
pari au minimum à 5 fois le nombre de
morts que nous avons et cet effet et
c'est un pari qui est basée sur quelque
chose de totalement incertain d'antan du
scientifique scientifique le fait que
les enfants retournent à l'école est ce
que ça vous inquiète on nous a toujours
présenté les enfants comme des grands
vecteurs de la maladie vous étiez étonné
par cette annonce hier soir alors on à
faire certaines personnes ont annoncé
les enfants comme vecteur de la maladie
mais je vous rappelle que la plupart des
enfants sont pas aussi symptomatique
c'est à dire avec peu de symptômes et
que les études qui ont été faites sur
les enfants montrent que les enfants
sécrète peu de virus donc c'est bien la
multiplicité des contacts cocon les
enfants entre eux qui guide cette
idéologie mais c'est pas une idéologie
qui était prouvée scientifiquement
dans le cadre du que vide donc non moi
ça m'inquiète qu'à moitié mais on n'a
pas de vraie réponse
aucun mot hier sur le traitement à la
chloroquine gens parlent évidemment
parce que ça vous le savez suscité une
forme de polémique certains notamment
chez les républicains sont étonnés qu on
la teste pas plus systématiquement
ça vous a étonné
vous aurez ce qui est étonnant c'est de
se rendre trois heures à marseille avec
le professeur raoul t puis de ne pas en
parler
cinq jours après ou trois jours après je
suis exactement combien de jours le
temps finis temps de passer à gauche
beaucoup plus vite que la normale
donc c'est politiquement je ne n'ai pas
de jugement politique sur la veille sur
la question alors autre point qu'a
abordé le président c'était une des
grandes inquiétudes des médecins
actuellement les patients atteints de
maladies chroniques et d'autres maladies
d'ailleurs ont déserté les cabinets est
ce qu'il ya un beau progrès sur ce point
les appels à la prudence ont été
entendus alors je vous disais la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vu que moi
dans mon cabinet je n'avais que le à peu
près 80% de mes patients qui venaient au
cabinet ce qui était nettement plus que
la normale je continue sur ce rythme là
aujourd'hui
avec ma femme nous avons eu plus de 80
patients avec 30% de personnes qui sont
encore et qui sont que vide donc je moi
j'en ai pas le sentiment mais je sais
qu'en france effectivement beaucoup de
médecins
enfin on une souffre d'une baisse
d'activité ce qui est paradoxal et je
pense qu'il faut juste se rendre
disponible est allé répondre plus
facilement au téléphone que on a en
avait l'habitude avant merci beaucoup
docteur le grand médecin généraliste à
tourcoing merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france